ADDY OSMANI: Hey guys.
And welcome to "The Breakpoint,"
a brand new show
on Google Developers Live,
where we're going to be
focusing on DevTools and
tooling in general.
My name is Addy Osmani and
joining me is Paul Irish.
PAUL LEWIS: That's not
technically true.
ADDY OSMANI: Who are you?
PAUL LEWIS: I'm Paul Lewis.
ADDY OSMANI: You're
not Paul Irish.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
I'm not Paul Irish.
I made a mask to try and
cover up for the fact.
I don't think it worked
out if I'm honest.
Yeah, I'm Paul Lewis, Developer
Programs engineer at Google.
The reason I'm standing
in for Paul Irish
today is he's unwell.
So get better soon, Paul.
ADDY OSMANI: Get well soon!
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So we're
here to talk about
DevTools and Yeoman.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, we're
here to talk about
DevTools and tooling.
Tooling's important.
There have been a lot of
developers recently that have
been starting to take a long,
hard look at their workflow
and the different tools
that they use on
a day-to-day basis.
And hopefully in the show over
the next couple of episodes,
we're going to give you some
tips and tricks on how you can
improve your workflow and
the tools that you use.
So, Paul?
PAUL LEWIS: Yup.
ADDY OSMANI: What do you
think about tooling?
PAUL LEWIS: So well, we
were talking about
this earlier today.
And we were talking about the
kind of things that you do
almost on a day-to-day basis,
like when you start an
application for the
first time.
You go off and you get the
dependencies that you need,
the libraries.
Maybe you even look around and
say, well, what do I need?
You'll come to this conclusion,
I'm going to do,
say, an MVC app.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, so I'm going to
maybe get Backbone or Ember
or one of these things.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, or Angular.
Something like that, yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Yup,
Angular, yeah.
So then I go off and
I download that.
Find maybe the repo,
go and get that.
Start coding.
There's a bit of fun in the
middle of there where I'm
constantly back and forth,
iterating in my editor and
also checking in the browser
back and forth.
And then I build it because I
want to compress my assets--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: --and you get all
the scripts together.
ADDY OSMANI: That's sounds
awfully manual.
There's like a whole lot of
manual grunt work there.
PAUL LEWIS: If I'm honest,
if I'm doing grunt
work, I like it.
If I'm honest, that is pretty
much how I used build apps.
And I understand that Yeoman
is going to help me out.
ADDY OSMANI: Well, hopefully,
it will.
We found that a lot of
developers are pretty much
doing exactly what Paul
Lewis is doing.
It's like they're manually
going and getting their
dependencies.
They're manually writing out
an awful lot of boilerplate
code whenever they want to
create a new application.
And we think that instead of
being one of those developers
that take like 45 minutes to get
set up whenever you want
to create a new project,
you should just
like take five minutes.
If you've got your workflow down
properly, it should just
take you 5 or 10 minutes.
And then you can have a working
prototype going just
soon after if you've got
your workflow down.
So we're going to give you some
tips on how to do that
today with Yeoman.
But before we do that, we're
going to take a look at some
of the new stuff that's landed
in the Chrome DevTools, or
Developer Tools, over the
past couple months.
So let me switch to my screen.
OK, so this is Chrome Stable
at the moment.
And I guess one of the big
things that we added in the
past couple months was better
support for mobile debugging
and debugging your mobile
web apps just
as easily as possible.
So I'm currently in Settings
at the moment.
Let me exit that out.
Most people who are familiar
with the Developer Tools
probably know that you can go
into the cog at the very right
corner of the screen,
and that will open
up a bunch of settings.
You can then go to the Overrides
tab, and in there,
you'll see a few options.
You'll see User Agent,
Device Metrics, and
Emulate Touch Events.
Now, just to give you a quick
visual demo of what this does,
if I go and I select User Agent,
so I pick a specific
browser or perhaps a browser
pair with an operating system
I go and I configure some device
metrics, I can actually
go and preview what this
site looks like.
So I'm previewing what
google.com looks like on an
iPhone using iOS 5.
And I've set my device metrics
to have a set screen
resolution of 320 by 480.
I can also change the font scale
factor if I want to see
how fonts may render differently
on mobile devices.
And I can also emulate
touch events.
I'm not going to show you
how that works just yet.
But it's--
what do you think, Paul?
Is it useful?
PAUL LEWIS: That's amazing,
actually.
So you can quickly choose--
like you say, I want
to see what this
looks like for an iPhone.
I want to see what this looks
like-- what else do we
have in that list?
ADDY OSMANI: Oh, we've
got a ton of stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
ADDY OSMANI: We've got iPads,
Android devices, BlackBerrys,
and then the browsers that
you're used to on desktop.
And we've got other options as
well in case you want to
customize it.
PAUL LEWIS: I like it.
ADDY OSMANI: We've got a ton
of options in there.
But this is useful.
I was about to show people
Chrome Canary and some of the
new stuff in there.
Do you use Canary for your--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So I think this is what we
say regularly anyway.
Because you can have Canary
alongside Chrome Stable.
So it's kind of good to
have Canary open.
You can see what's kind of
coming down the line and just
check that everything still
play nicely, get
access to new features.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
PAUL LEWIS: Which is I'm pretty
sure what you're going
to do here.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
PAUL LEWIS: And have Stable
alongside it so you can
actually see what all your users
are seeing when they're
building your app.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, so most of
the time, I think people will
be using Chrome Stable when
they're testing out, like you
said, what their
users have got.
But if you want to be using the
latest, hottest features
in the Chrome Developer Tools
there's no reason why you
can't be using Canary for
your debugging instead.
So I'm going to show
you some new stuff.
Before we go and try out some
features, if you take a look
at Chrome Flags--
PAUL LEWIS: Which you should
do anyway, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Because there's
tons of really cool
things you can do.
ADDY OSMANI: There is so
much stuff in here.
PAUL LEWIS: The one I've been
playing with recently is the
ability to pipe the microphone
through to the Web Audio API,
which is amazing.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, that
stuff just landed
recently, too, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Just the last
couple of weeks.
So that's a really good way to
see, as we said, what's coming
down the line.
So definitely like to
do some of that.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
So because we're looking at
the Developer Tools at the
moment, scroll down to the
option that says Enable
Developer Tools Experiments.
And this a new option that will
let you take a look at
some of the features
that we've been
working on very recently.
They're not all finished
and polished off.
But you can try them right away
and see what's going on
and if they're going to be
useful to your workflow.
So I've gone and I've
enabled them.
I need to actually go and
relaunch my browser now, just
so those changes will
take effect.
That will load up
very quickly.
I've got all my tabs back,
which is awesome.
And now, I'm just going to
go back to tab I was on.
And let's go through some
of the features.
So I'm clicking on the
cog once again.
And now you'll notice
that we have a new
Experiments tab, right?
So let's go to Experiments.
I've going to bump up the font
size a little bit so people
can see these.
Now, you see a warning
at the very top.
Basically, these experiments
are subject to change.
They're not finalized
or stable just yet.
But you can try them out.
So some of things on this list--
have you been using any
of this stuff?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
I've been using the file
system inspection one.
ADDY OSMANI: What
does that do?
PAUL LEWIS: So it gives you--
alongside all the other
resources that you see, so any
the Index DB tables all those
kind things, you'll see a new
one appear at the bottom,
which is the File System.
So anything you use, anything
you store using the Chrome
File System is available
there.
So it's really convenient if
you just wanted to see what
Chrome actually stored under the
hood when you use the file
system API.
ADDY OSMANI: That is so cool.
So there's a bunch
of stuff in here.
There's Snippet support.
There's CSS Regions support.
So have you taken a look
at CSS Regions before?
PAUL LEWIS: I have.
ADDY OSMANI: You have?
You going to show us?
ADDY OSMANI: I'm not going to
show a demo of this just yet.
I want to show people Snippets
and some other things.
But basically with CSS
Regions, we have some
experimental support of how you
can go and inspect name
flows on the page and take a
look at sort of any other
highlighted regions that you
want to see in your document
at the moment, which is cool.
We've got a bunch
of other stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: I like this Override
Device Geolocation.
That's really handy.
Because again if you
find yourself--
you're building the site
with geolocation.
You're like, yeah, but
how does this work
in the middle of--
I was going to say in the
middle of London.
I'm in the middle of London.
Well done, Paul.
The middle of the US.
I'm not there.
I'm in London.
So that would be brilliant
for that.
ADDY OSMANI: This sounds like
the type of feature that would
let me change your location--
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: --if I wanted to.
This sounds exciting.
PAUL LEWIS: That's mean.
ADDY OSMANI: You were expecting
anything else?
PAUL LEWIS: No, I wasn't.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, right.
All right so Override
Device Geolocation.
What does that do?
So if we go back--
let's enable it first of all.
So Override Device
Geolocation.
Let's enable a few of these so
I can actually show them to
you, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Presumably we need
a restart there, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, we need
to reopen the DevTools.
Whoop.
And now you'll see that there's
a bunch of other
overrides that have introduced
since the Overrides tab.
Now with Override Geolocation,
if I were to select that I can
then go and type in custom
long/lat details, which I can
use when I'm debugging
my applications.
So I don't have to go and worry
about hard coding values
or anything like that
into my app.
I can just do it while I'm
debugging and have my app sort
of react to that, which
is pretty cool.
Another thing that we've got
is the ability to override
device orientation.
So if you wanted to sort of
see what would happen if
someone turned around the
devices they're using--
PAUL LEWIS: It's almost like you
wouldn't want to take your
laptop and go, whee, with it.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
And there have been people that
have been doing that.
PAUL LEWIS: Really?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
I've seen people in some
offices doing that.
PAUL LEWIS: Well,
that's awkward.
ADDY OSMANI: It's crazy.
PAUL LEWIS: Imagine the
looks you'd get.
And now through the power of the
Chrome DevTools, no more.
PAUL LEWIS: You've got them.
It's awesome.
So one other thing that I
enabled was something called
Snippets support.
Have you used Snippets before?
PAUL LEWIS: I have
used Snippets.
But what are you going
to do here?
ADDY OSMANI: What am
I going to do here?
I'm just going to show you
what Snippets are.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, I like it.
ADDY OSMANI: So we've got a
bunch of tabs in Chrome
Developer Tools.
If I go to sources and you've
enabled Snippets in the
experiments, you can actually
go to a Snippets sub-tab.
And you're able to now sort
of create new Snippets.
And Snippets are basically just
blocks of scripts that
you can create, save, or
execute, and easily store them
inside the DevTools in
case you want to
use them at any point.
So I can go and I can add in
custom functions doing--
or something.
I don't know.
You could have any sort of
function you want in here and
just have it execute.
And it all works.
It's pretty neat.
PAUL LEWIS: So how would
you then use
that Snippet in your--
so you've created
this Snippet--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, so you can
go and run this if you want.
This code isn't going to run
because it doesn't actually
have anything in there.
But you can then go and
run these Snippets
any time you want.
You can have them interact
with the page if
you want to do that.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, OK.
ADDY OSMANI: And it's just
supposed to be a nice little
addition to your work.
PAUL LEWIS: So let's so you
created some kind of script
that helps you debug.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So I mean I'm
very much in the GPU and
performance thing.
So I'm very much kind of
thinking, hey, I could have a
little Snippet that could do
something crazy with the WebGL
context that I only want to
do when I'm debugging.
I don't want to include it
as a script to my thing.
I could create a Snippet.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
PAUL LEWIS: I just run that
whenever I've got a problem.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
And you can just go straight
back into the Snippets tab and
run that code any time
you want, which is
really, really fun.
PAUL LEWIS: Sold.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome.
So one other thing I wanted
to talk about.
So we've taken a look
at some of the
experiments in Chrome Canary.
We've taken a look at
what's in stable.
One other thing that we think
developers should care about
are the Developer Tools
Extensions that are available
at the moment.
One that I've written about
previously was called Tincr.
And I'm going to show you a
preview of what Tincr does.
It's pretty awesome.
So I'm just going to serve
up a directory.
This is my TodoMVC project.
And I probably want to go and
switch off my overrides just
so I can see the entire page.
It's so cool.
PAUL LEWIS: You see how
easy that was, right?
ADDY OSMANI: That's
really nice.
PAUL LEWIS: He just takes that
box over and takes that one
check, that box.
ADDY OSMANI: It's so nice.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: Now, Tincr is
there's something that's
available over at the Tincr
website, so tin.cr.
And what Tincr does is it allows
you to make changes
within the Developer Tools to a
page and have those changes
actually be saved and persist to
your original source files.
So if I made like style changes
or changes to script
or anything like that, those
changes can actually be saved
to the source files.
PAUL LEWIS: This is what I was
talking about earlier.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Like when you're
building an application and
then you're like, oh, I'll
switch to Chrome.
Ah, I'll just change that in
the DevTools because that
color's slightly off.
And then you kind of have to
remember if you make like 10
or 15 changes--
ADDY OSMANI: It's a big deal.
You've got to copy those
things over here.
Or you have to make sure
that you don't
like reload your page.
It's a pain.
PAUL LEWIS: Or if you do reload
your page, you're like,
no, I've lost all
those things.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
Exactly.
Right, so with Tincr, what you
do is you first choose the
type of project that
you're working on.
I'm currently inside a new
Tincr tab that's in the
DevTools, which you'll have when
you install it, right?
So I'm selecting the type of
project I'm working on.
I'm going to browse to the root
of where this project is
because Tincr requires that.
And by default, it'll
automatically refresh to sort
of show you the changes
that you've made.
And it'll automatically save.
So let me refresh my page very
quickly and go back.
And let's say we want
to make a change.
Like let's say I want to change
the color of my buttons
to something else.
PAUL LEWIS: I, for one, am
disappointed you didn't change
it to Comic Sans, that you went
straight to the color
thing there.
But, you know, each
to their own.
I can't fault you for just
changing the color.
ADDY OSMANI: This is really the
standard of developer we
were able to get instead
of Paul Irish.
It's heartbreaking.
PAUL LEWIS: Desparate times,
desperate measures.
Any port in a storm,
I believe is the--
ADDY OSMANI: Pretty much.
Pretty much.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
So I've gone and I've
changed the color of
my buttons to blue.
Now, as long as you know nothing
has broken, nothing's
gone wrong, when I refresh my
page, and you can confirm I've
just refreshed my page--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: --the changes
have persisted.
And if go and I take a look at
source of this document, what
you'll find is that in my style
sheet that change has
been saved.
So I don't even have to go
back to my editor or
anything like that.
The change is saved, and
it's already there.
What's even cooler is if you go
to Sources and you take a
look at where this stuff is--
so let me go to Sources and
figure out what file
I was working in.
I can right click on a file
and take a look at local
modifications to it.
So let's see what local
modifications remain.
I think it was this file.
Where are we?
Let's see.
So it's because I've
refreshed it.
Let's just make another change
so I can actually take a look
at local modifications.
So let's say we've changed
this to green, right?
I go to Sources.
Let's see if this will work.
So now what you'll see in local
modifications is all the
changes that I've made
to this file.
And you actually get a
really, really nice
diff of those changes.
Depending on whether you've gone
and you've refreshed the
page or not, you can actually
see the entire history of what
you've been doing to the page
and decide about what changes
you want to keep and what
changes you don't want to
keep, which I think is useful.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I
was noticing that.
Because you've got a revert,
which I assume reverts all
changes that you made locally.
And then there's presumably
a per-change
Apply Original Content.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, and it'll
show you the time that you
made the changes
and everything.
It's really, really useful.
PAUL LEWIS: I like.
ADDY OSMANI: You like?
Excellent.
Right.
So we've shown you some stuff in
the Chrome Developer Tools.
Let's talk a little bit more
about tooling and how we can
solve some of the problems
you talked about earlier.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
Because earlier we
established that
basically my workflow sucks.
Now, I'll be honest.
I've moved on a little
bit from that point.
But nonetheless--
ADDY OSMANI: Notice
he said little.
Just a little.
Tiny amount.
OK.
PAUL LEWIS: But all the same, I
think parts of that workflow
still remain for me.
And I think, like we said, for a
lot of developers, it's very
much kind of the situation.
It's very difficult
to just shift.
Because people have
got deadlines.
They've got these things to--
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, of course.
PAUL LEWIS: --the actual
coding to do.
So I guess we're going to talk
about Yeoman, right?
ADDY OSMANI: We're
going to talk a
little bit about Yeoman.
PAUL LEWIS: Solid.
ADDY OSMANI: Awesome, right.
So Yeoman is basically an
opinionated workflow for
creating compelling modern
web applications.
For people that haven't tried it
out yet or haven't checked
out the site, we're available
at yeoman.io.
And this is sort of a project
that a few people, so me, Paul
Irish, Sindre Sorhus,
and Mickael Daniel--
PAUL LEWIS: Paul Irish.
ADDY OSMANI: --Paul Irish
--created few months ago and
we've been working on it.
And it sort of builds on top of
a ton of other great tools
like Grunt and Twitter
Bootstrap and so on.
And I'm just going to show
you what it does.
It's easier to show than
just keep talking.
PAUL LEWIS: So one of the things
that you said, though,
was that this is an
opinionated tool.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: What do you mean
an opinionated tool?
ADDY OSMANI: Right.
So there are like a huge ton of
options that people have on
the front end these days.
Like do you use SaaS,
Less, Compass?
There's a ton of options.
And then you have a whole other
side of things when it
comes to like the JavaScript
that you write for apps.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
ADDY OSMANI: Like are you
talking about using specific
frameworks?
Or how do you structure
your whole app,
and all those things.
There's a lot of stuff that
people have to think about it.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: And we thought
what if we were to try
capturing what we think is the
best set of options for you
develop a modern app into
a single workflow.
And that's basically
what Yeoman is.
It's a bunch of tools brought
together that
we hope works well.
So let me take you to a demo
of Yeoman and show you how
that works.
OK, so I've got my screen
open at the moment.
And I'm going to also have a
text editor that I'm going to
switch to you in just a sec.
Right, so with Yeoman to
kickstart off our new project,
you just use Yeoman Init.
So I've typed in Yeoman Init.
Waiting for this to go and
ask me some questions.
So when you sort of fire this
off, it'll go ask you some
questions about what you want
to do in your application.
Like do you want to include
Twitter Bootstrap?
Do you want to include the
Twitter Bootstrap plug-ins?
Because like, let's face it,
when you're developing a
prototype, you want something
that's pretty.
It doesn't have to be the
prettiest thing in the world.
You don't have to go necessarily
using Bootstrap in
production, but it's great
for prototypes, right?
So do you want to include the
Twitter Bootstrap plug-ins?
If you're a JavaScript app
developer, maybe you want to
use RequireJS and AMD.
So we'll ask you about
that as well.
PAUL LEWIS: So I assume the
questions that it's asking are
based on your experience, Paul
Irish's experience, the team's
experience on the kind of tools
that people need and
want in their workflow, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, absolutely.
PAUL LEWIS: Cool.
ADDY OSMANI: So, while you're
talking, basically what it's
gone and it's done is it's gone
and fetched the latest
version of all these
dependencies, and it's put
them into a local directory that
you can use for your app.
We've also gone and sort of
scaffolded out some very basic
unit tests.
Unit testing's important.
Do you unit test your code?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes?
PAUL LEWIS: Not always.
ADDY OSMANI: Not always.
PAUL LEWIS: If I'm honest,
not always.
But if it's built in,
it makes it easier.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, good.
So we do that stuff for you.
And you can then go and like
preview what this has created
using server command.
So I'm guessing in previous
years when you're like a web
app developer and working with
a bunch of other code, maybe
you used like Map or Wamp
or all that stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: Always
one of those.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
So we thought why don't we just
add this to a command and
fire off a server.
So if you type in Yeoman Server,
it'll actually go and
fire off a server using the
contents of the application
that you working on
just right now.
And it'll actually show
you a preview.
So on screen at the moment, we
have a preview of our compiled
Twitter Bootstrap files.
We were using Compass sources.
So this is complied Twitter
Bootstrap files.
You have HTML5 Boilerplate.
You have RequireJS and
a few other pieces.
And you can go and start coding
right away which is
fun, right?
So one other thing I wanted to
show you guys was how Yeoman
can help you with something
called LiveReload.
Have you heard of LiveReload
before?
PAUL LEWIS: Let's assume
I have not.
That would make life a lot
easier for you right now,
wouldn't it?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
Yes, it would.
OK, before I show
this to you, so
LiveReload is pretty awesome.
It's this functionality that
allows you to make changes in
your application, whether it's
your style sheets, or your
scripts, your markup or
anything, and have the browser
automatically reload whenever
changes are made
to your local files.
So you don't have to go and
refresh it yourself.
You get this constant sort of
parallel view of what's going
on in the browser and what's
going on in your source.
So let's see if this
works right now.
So I've just created a brand
new application.
I'm going to my index and let me
see about replacing Wotcha!
with Wotcha Paul!
And as we can see it's gone,
and it's automatically
reloaded the page.
I didn't have to do
anything at all.
It's gone, and it's compiled
the compass files.
If I had copied script, it
would be automatically
compiling that stuff for me.
If I had RequireJS files, it'd
be doing the exact same thing.
And it's just really nice.
It means I don't have to go
and put together a whole
workflow and build process
that does this stuff.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
ADDY OSMANI: Which is nice.
Sort of on top of that, how were
you saying that you were
handling dependencies before?
You were manually going against
the web, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, The classic
situation is there's a new
version of a library, or I want
to add another library
after this point, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So we created a
project but it's like, ah, now
I realize I need this other
library in there.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So, yeah, I go off,
find it in framework's
like I did with my original
dependencies.
So I just go off, get it, and
drag it in, and hope for the
best, generally speaking.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
It's a pain.
It's, again, one of those
manual things
that you have to do.
You've got to go and open up
your browser and figure out
where the dependencies, whether
you're using the most
up-to-date version or not.
So we figured, well, why don't
we make this a little bit more
straightforward?
So let's say there's a
dependency you wanted.
You mentioned Backbone
apps earlier on.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, let's do it.
ADDY OSMANI: Let's see.
Let's say that we started
off with a very
basic application structure.
And we want to get Backbone
into our app.
So maybe the first thing that
we do is try to look and see
is Backbone available
via Yeoman?
And it's going to go and it's
going to search out.
And what you can see here on
the screen at the moment is
that not only is Backbone
available, but there are a ton
of Backbone extensions and
adapters and plug-ins also
available as well.
And I can easily install any of
these via the command line.
So if I were to do Yeoman
install Backbone just to start
us off, that'll go and it'll
install Backbone for me.
PAUL LEWIS: What happens if I do
this and then there's a new
version of Backbone
released tomorrow?
It's early on in the project.
I feel like I've got the room.
I can test this in
this new version.
What do I do then?
How does that work?
ADDY OSMANI: Then all you have
to do is we have-- similar to
install, we have an
update command.
So if you typed in "yeoman
update backbone," it would go
and it would get the
latest version of
Backbone for you as well.
And something you may have
noticed, some people may have
noticed, is if you take a look
at the lines in here, you'll
notice that it didn't just
go and fetch Backbone.
It actually went and it fetched
Underscore as well.
So we're using Twitter's Bower
project as our package
management registry.
And when we typed in "yeoman
install backbone," it went and
it tried to fetch the latest
version of Backbone, figured
out that Backbone has a few
other dependencies, and it
also went and grabbed
those dependencies
for us, which is--
PAUL LEWIS: That's awesome
because, yeah, it's like you
may have, as you say,
dependencies on dependencies.
Dependency-ception.
ADDY OSMANI: Dependency-ception.
PAUL LEWIS: I love it.
ADDY OSMANI: Of course you do.
PAUL LEWIS: Why wouldn't I?
ADDY OSMANI: God knows.
God knows.
OK, so we've covered previewing
stuff and what you
do when you're writing a
very basic application.
Then you've got your build
process, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,.
So right.
So this is the point at which,
let's call him old Paul.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
Old Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: The unreformed.
The unwashed.
I would probably write myself,
oh, let's see, an ANT script.
I would use a UE.jar
or something like
that to go off and--
hey, I've been around
a while--
to concatenate and minify my
JavaScript, minify my CSS,
make it all good.
And then I sort of manually
change the paths and all that
kind of stuff in my app.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: And be like,
yeah, this works
with my minified version.
And then push it out live.
ADDY OSMANI: Cool.
PAUL LEWIS: You've got something
better for me?
ADDY OSMANI: Hopefully.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: Right, so we took
a long, hard look at how
people were actually building
their projects.
And, like we said, there's a ton
of tools people use on the
front end these says.
You've got like SaaS and
CoffeeScript and RequireJS and
what have you.
And then when you're trying
to deploy something to
production, you also have to
care about optimizing the rest
of your project.
Like not just the stuff you're
used to like minification and
concatenation, but also things
like revving your files and
optimizing all of the images
in your project as well.
Now, some people, when you're
putting together your own
build process, you might just
go and say, OK, well, I'm
going to pick an image
optimization library.
Cool, it'll do its own
stuff for me, right?
What we did was we actually went
and researched all of the
most popular image optimization
solutions that
are available.
And we picked the two most
efficient ones in terms of
making sure that you get as
lasting an experience as
possible with the small
file sizes as well.
And when you run Yeoman
Build, this is
where the magic happens.
It'll actually go and it'll
build out your entire project.
It'll compile any sort of
abstractions that you're using.
As you can see, it's both
running a number of tasks on
your images as well
as other stuff.
And there we have it.
The project is completely
done.
I've just finished off a
sentence and my project is now
ready for me to deploy to
production if I wanted it.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm blown away.
ADDY OSMANI: It's done.
That is amazing.
PAUL LEWIS: Done
without errors.
ADDY OSMANI: Done without
errors, yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: That's unusual
for me, certainly.
But let's carry on.
ADDY OSMANI: We're hoping
that this will
improve you as a developer.
PAUL LEWIS: Whoa.
ADDY OSMANI: This
is specifically
built for you, Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Wow.
I am so lucky.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, so we've taken
a look at the Yeoman
workflow and how it works
for basic projects.
I'm going to talk very quickly
about generators.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
ADDY OSMANI: So you
were talking.
PAUL LEWIS: So one of the things
that came up when we
were talking about Yeoman and
I was asking some questions
is, OK, you do something
like Backbone.
But there are these models,
there's controllers, there's
all those kinds of things that
you do as well, right?
So what if I don't
want Backbone.
What if I actually want to start
a project with Angular
or Backbone or any of these?
Do I have to go through this
multi-step process with
Yeoman, or can we kind of
shortcut this whole thing?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
So Yeoman, with them, we wanted
to do something fun.
So we put it over the generator
system in Rails,
over the node, and we make
available a bunch of
different, what we
call, scaffolds.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: Scaffold
degenerators that allow you to
scaffold out new projects
using an MVC framework.
So we've got a bunch of them
that we support at the moment.
We've got Angular,
Backbone, Ember.
And a bunch of others.
And the idea is that rather
than you having to go and
write the boilerplate for a new
model, or controller, or
router, we'll actually
do that for you.
Let me show you a very
quick preview.
And I guess then we're going to
be introducing our special
guess for today.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, yes.
ADDY OSMANI: We've got
a special guest.
So let's say that I want to
start up a brand new project.
We're going to call
this Paul L.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, is
this for me?
ADDY OSMANI: Is this
jinxing it?
PAUL LEWIS: Well, yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: It has to.
PAUL LEWIS: It's going to
be erratic at best.
ADDY OSMANI: Probably.
PAUL LEWIS: If I'm honest.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, so let's say
I'm doing Yeoman and Backbone.
I want to create a new
Backbone application.
And what you've seen it go and
do just now is scaffold out
everything I need for a very,
very basic Backbone app.
I've got my index.
I've got jQuery.
I've got Underscore
or Low-Dash.
I've got a bunch
of unit tests.
And I've also got my first
set of application files.
So I've got my first router, my
first view, template files,
model, collection.
And if you go into these files,
it'll actually contain
the boilerplate for each of
those pieces for you.
So you can just focus
on writing the
logic for your app.
Now, that's cool and all.
But I think people will like to
see what the Angular guys
have been working on.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: This has
been pretty awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
So the AngularJS team
were pretty awesome.
They came in early on in
the Yeoman project.
And they were like, well, can we
actually build a generator
that can replace some of the
other Angular projects at the
moment that are trying to help
people with scaffolding?
And can Yeoman help give a
much better generation
experience for people so
they don't have to
write as much code?
So I'm happy to introduce Brian
Ford from the Angular
team who is going to be showing
us some of the stuff
that he's been working on
Angular to do with Yeoman.
BRIAN FORD: All right.
Hey, guys.
So as Addy said, I'm from
the Angular team.
I was tasked with doing some
exploratory work and seeing
how Yeoman could really
help us out.
And I was really pleasantly
surprised.
We experimented with this
thing that we called the
Angular seed, which
was kind of like a
boilerplate for Angular.
So it gave you kind of a
folder structure and an
index.html that's pretty
inspired by HTML5 boilerplate,
and some other stuff.
And we have a pretty vibrant
open source community.
And we had a lot of people work
this project and kind of
say, well, I want
SaaS support.
I want Bootstrap in there,
or I want RequireJS.
I want these different things.
And so we were really excited
about Yeoman because it was
really a pain to--
every time we released a new
version or there were some API
change, all these projects
had to change.
And it was just a big hassle.
And there wasn't like one
definitive like here's where
you should go for the best
practices for starting a new
Angular app.
So I think Yeoman's a really
exciting project for not just
Angular, but any of these new
MVC frameworks to look at.
So with that in mind, some of
the generators that I wrote,
they not only just generate
models, views, controllers,
directives, which is something
awesome in Angular.
By the way, if you guys haven't
checked out Angular
yet, you definitely should.
It's a really cool library.
It's a really fresh
approach, I think.
And I think that you'll find
that it also really helps
speed up the app building
process.
So a quick plug there.
Check it out if you haven't.
But it does all these things.
But it not only does these,
but it'll rewrite routing
configurations, and it makes
little tweaks to other files
in a really non-destructive
way.
So we're not just rewriting
some file every time.
It's going in there, and
it's rewriting things.
So it keep all of
your changes.
But as you add new routes and
things, it'll automatically
give you that boilerplate code
there so you can just keep
hacking away on your app.
So I'm going to switch then over
to my screen and give a
quick demo of what this
actually looks like.
All right.
Oh, there we go.
PAUL LEWIS: Look at those
gorgeous people on his screen.
ADDY OSMANI: There
are so pretty.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, I know.
BRIAN FORD: So here we
are at our terminal.
I'm going to do a Yeoman
Init Angular.
So Addy showed off what happens
when you run Yeoman
Init Backbone, I think it was.
But we have pretty much the
same thing going on here,
perhaps a few less choices.
So would you like to include
Twitter Bootstrap?
Yes, for sure.
Twitter Bootstrap's awesome.
Would you like to use Twitter
Bootstrap for Compass, which
is an extension of SaaS?
So it's the SaaS version.
Yes, that's awesome.
I love SaaS.
So there we go.
Bam.
It created a ton of files.
You'll see there are a lot of
these different style things.
But then also it gives you some
common Angular files,
sets up your application, sets
up a single controller.
And it also sets up--
here, this is one of the coolest
things about the
Angular generators, is it also
sets up a unit test by default
for everything that you make.
So you're already set up
to do unit testing.
You don't have to fiddle
around with
some boilerplate code.
It'll automatically
put that in there.
And so that's really cool.
Unit testing's a really, really
huge part of developing
AngularJS apps.
We want web apps to be really
robust and testable.
And we want to have these
tools to support
that sort of workflow.
So let's see what this
looks like right now.
So my Linus box is goofy.
I think it's going to
launch up Firefox.
But we're going to ignore
that and go to Chrome.
There we go there's Firefox.
Cheerio!
All right.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh, the irony.
BRIAN FORD: Yeah, the irony.
So here you can see you might
recognize the Twitter
Bootstrap here.
And it says we have these
things installed.
So let's go ahead and go into
Apps Script Controller Main.
Ooh, that's some big font.
All right.
Let's add another
item in there.
Let's see, technically we
also have Bootstrap,
so let's add that.
And we save it, and we get that
auto-refresh awesomeness.
So that's pretty cool.
But let's see how we can further
support building an
Angular app with Yeoman.
So let's say I want
another route.
Maybe I'll open up a new tab
in my terminal here.
So we would do Yeoman
Init Angular route.
Maybe I'll do like "hi, Paul,"
or something like that.
PAUL LEWIS: I like this theme.
ADDY OSMANI: I think perhaps
he was referring
to our other Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Oh.
BRIAN FORD: We can do a "hi,
other Paul" as well.
PAUL LEWIS: I said at
the start, we're
hot-swappable, you know?
You just pick a Paul.
It's all good.
BRIAN FORD: Full Paul
interpolation?
PAUL LEWIS: Absolutely.
BRIAN FORD: All right.
PAUL LEWIS: You get increasing
amount of hair.
BRIAN FORD: And you can actually
just go to "hi,
Paul." And this is the
"hi, Paul" view.
But let's add something in
here so that way we can
navigate around.
It's hard to scroll through
these things we you have this
awesome huge text.
OK.
So maybe we add a nav
element here.
And we say that this goes to
"hi, Paul." One of the things
that we're working on right
now is supporting HTML5
routing by defaults in Yeoman.
Right now we don't do that.
But I think there's actually a
pending pull request that adds
that so that you don't have to
have this ugly little hashmap.
Then we can just do
home, I guess.
All right, so we've got home and
we've got "hi, Paul," so
that's pretty cool.
We already set up some really
simple routing.
And if we check our app here,
here's where it actually set
up this routing.
So you'll see we have both the
"hi, Paul" and the "hi, other
Paul." And it already configured
a controller and
the view, and it has it
already hooked up.
And if we wanted to
do maybe add like
some ID in here, right?
Then this will persist
even if I were to add
another route to it.
So all of these changes that you
make, they're not going to
get overwritten by
the generators.
ADDY OSMANI: That's awesome.
It's seems like--
BRIAN FORD: And actually
there's--
sorry, what was that?
ADDY OSMANI: It seems like
almost the process of building
Angular app has in many cases
been replaced by just a few
lines of the command line.
BRIAN FORD: Yeah, I mean,
it's very simply.
You just write a few things in
the command line, and then you
basically just open up your
controller, and you're just
like right in the meat and
potatoes of your app.
So, for instance, if I wanted
to make it so I could edit
this list right now, it's
actually really super simple.
So we just want to expose--
this is like Angular jargon
here, but we just want to
expose onto our scope a method
that maybe adds to our list of
awesome things.
So I'll push scope.new
awesome thing.
And this is like some awesome
Angular almost voodoo we have
going on here.
So if we go over here to our
main view, we can just add an
input box here.
And we can say ng-model equals
new awesome thing and then
maybe we want an input.
I'll make this look nice because
we're using Bootstrap,
ng-click=add.
PAUL LEWIS: I love this
Because you've
gone straight into--
like we're saying, all the set
up-y type stuff, the really,
really dull stuff, if I'm
honest, like the wiring this
and the-- less wiring and
more actual fun stuff.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Let's face it.
ADDY OSMANI: I'm guessing that
if he kept on going for like
another 10 or 20 minutes, he
would easily have a nice
prototype of his app.
PAUL LEWIS: I love it.
ADDY OSMANI: It's awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: I've got a feeling
he's about to add
something to this list.
BRIAN FORD: Yup.
PAUL LEWIS: Boom, there it is.
ADDY OSMANI: Sweet.
That is awesome.
BRIAN FORD: I don't know if you
guys can see it very well.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, yes, we can.
BRIAN FORD: Yeah, again, I think
Angular and Yeoman are a
great team together.
Angular really focuses on
minimal boilerplate.
But no matter what framework you
use, you're still going to
have different references
across files, different
controllers, and views and
things that you need to link
together when you're making
these new things.
And so Yeoman is really
cool for that.
And plus you get all of the
awesome things that Addy
mentioned earlier.
The build process is there.
The testing is there, just all
these things, the image
minification.
So it's just really,
really awesome.
I couldn't imagine developing
apps any other
way since using Yeoman.
PAUL LEWIS: That's what you
want to hear, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
PAUL LEWIS: That's wonderful.
Awesome.
Yeah, thank you so much, Brian,
for showing us through
the Angular generators.
That's awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
I guess what we should do is we
should take a look at the
questions on the Moderator.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
We're almost out of time so
let's look at some questions.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, let's
see what we've got.
So we maybe not be able to get
through all 13 questions, but
thank you for them.
And we will obviously get
through the ones that we can.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So let's start
with the top one.
So first, "congrats on the
successful launch." That's
very kind of you. "Plans on
letting people define their
own code structure.
Today it's rather hard to
introduce Yeoman into an
existing environment due to
the requirements on folder
structure, et cetera." Also,
as a bonus here, "Windows
support soon?"
ADDY OSMANI: So people have been
requesting the ability to
drop in existing projects into
Yeoman and just have it work.
And we totally get that.
So we're taking a look at better
initial configuration
so that if you have a project
with a different directory
structure to what we think you
should be using, we're going
to give you a nice easy way in
the next couple of releases to
just sort of say, OK, well,
here's where my scripts are.
Here's where my styles are.
And here's how the rest of
my app is structured.
And hopefully, you'll be able
to just use Yeoman right out
of the box without
too many issues.
PAUL LEWIS: So on that, though,
it's presumably worth
saying that Yeoman still
is opinionated.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
PAUL LEWIS: And that is
a core part of Yeoman.
So it's probably, what?
A compromise somewhere
in there?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So it's like,
yes, you can tweak
things a little bit.
But do expect it to still
be Yeoman-ish.
ADDY OSMANI: Absolutely.
And we always tell people if
you find that what you're
trying to do is a little bit
too much outside of our own
opinions, we do recommend,
though, do check out Grunts,
which is a project that
Yeoman builds on.
Because it allows you to
customize a lot more.
It's more for those people that
know what they're doing.
They've got a good idea of all
the tools they want to support
and want something a
lot more custom.
There's also a question
about Windows support.
So we don't officially support
Windows just yet.
But I will say I was doing
a tooling workshop in
Amsterdam last week.
And I'd say half the class had
Windows boxes, and they were
all up and using Yeoman.
So it does work at the moment.
There are one or two little
tweaks we still have to make
to improve the user
experience.
But Windows support is coming.
It's definitely something
that's on our radar.
PAUL LEWIS: Awesome.
OK, so "can Yeoman be expanded
for other languages, such as
PHP?"
ADDY OSMANI: Interesting
question.
So quite a few people have also
been saying, you know,
I've got an existing back end.
Maybe it's written in PHP,
or Rails, or .net,
or something else.
And we want to try helping
developers with the broader
stack as well.
There are a ton of different
variations on that, though.
And we obviously can't help
everybody with everything.
So what we're going to try doing
some time in the near
future is giving you a solution
for how you can
integrate your existing back
end with a front end that's
powered by a Yeoman workflow.
It's definitely something
that we're looking at.
And it'll probably just take
a little while longer to
properly think through
the design of that.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, that actually
taps into another question.
So you've answered that one
by proxy, which is great.
"It would be awesome"--
apparently--
"if Wordpress and other CMS
had integration as well."
ADDY OSMANI: It's interesting
when you say integration.
What do you think integration
means there?
PAUL LEWIS: Well, it's
a good question.
Well, the question here from
Simon, he's sort of saying
"Wordpress database, HTML5
boilerplate-themed build
script, boo."
ADDY OSMANI: So, actually, a
nice fellow called Romain
Berger came up with a Wordpress
generator for Yeoman.
I haven't taken a full
look at it just yet.
But the idea there is that
you can actually generate
Wordpress projects
using Yeoman.
PAUL LEWIS: I guess that
seems to be what
the question's asking.
It's like, OK, yeah.
Because if you were to scaffold
out today at front
end, it would be, I suppose,
ignorant of any particular CMS
or whatever.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: So it's good to
know that there are, in
theory, generators.
And yes, I mean, that's the
point of the community, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Definitely.
PAUL LEWIS: If you want to write
these generators, you
can look at the existing
generators, you
can create your own.
There's pull requests, as
you say, for Wordpress.
ADDY OSMANI: Absolutely.
PAUL LEWIS: So get involved.
Help out.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, that'd
be awesome.
PAUL LEWIS: That's what we're
hoping people will do.
ADDY OSMANI: Let's take
one more question and
then we're going to--
PAUL LEWIS: Can you talk a
little about Yeoman Insight?
What are the plans to
share this wonderful
data with the world?
Thank you, Eric.
ADDY OSMANI: Oh, of course.
Yes.
So Yeoman Insight was this idea
to help track some of the
different things that
developers are doing
on the front end.
The idea is that we don't really
have this sort of great
source of information about
what frameworks people are
using, whether people are
building large-scale
applications or something a
little bit smaller, what the
pain points of people's
workflows are.
And so Insight is sort of this
opt-in feature of Yeoman.
So it's completely optional.
You don't have to use it.
We do like you to, if you can.
But basically, it'll track some
of the stuff that you're
doing and send it back to us.
We aggregate the data.
And at some point in the near
future, we're going to share a
lot of that information.
So we'll let you know what
frameworks people have been
installing and using with their
apps, what the most
popular commands are, whether
people are just using Yeoman
for tons and tons of smaller
projects or just on much
larger beefier things
in production.
But, yeah, we're hopefully going
to plan on getting that
data out soon.
PAUL LEWIS: I know that you said
this was last question.
But I did see one at
the bottom here.
Is that Paul Irish
on the right?
I think, no.
Unless Paul Irish suddenly
became British.
There's Paul Irish
now on the left.
Unless Paul Irish became British
and lost all his hair.
No, I'm Paul Irish.
But Paul Irish is unwell
this week.
So hopefully he gets better.
ADDY OSMANI: Get well soon.
Get well soon.
So on that that's it.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you
for joining us.
ADDY OSMANI: Thank you to my
special guest, Paul Lewis, for
stepping in.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you.
ADDY OSMANI: And we'll see
you again on the next
"Breakpoint." Thank
you very much.
PAUL LEWIS: Thank you, Brian.
BRIAN FORD: Yup.
PAUL LEWIS: See you later.